hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in book 1 of on
the end Cicero has torquatus the
epicurean present the position of the
Epicureans on the virtues and one of
those that he engages with is courage so
courage like the other virtues from an
epicurean standpoint is not going to be
something valuable for its own sake it's
going to be instrumentally valuable
precisely because it leads us to a life
or it functions as a means to a life in
which we enjoy as much pleasure as
possible and suffer as little pain as
possible and courage is a little bit
different than the other virtues if you
think about temperance or wisdom and
justice which tend to have a sort of
balance in terms of pleasures and pains
in the presentation here there's not a
lot of discussion of pleasures there's a
lot more about avoiding pains so one
reason why we need courage is so that by
dealing with things that are painful in
the right way we don't wind up incurring
and suffering from even worse pains
there's a sort of
rado out there you could put it in terms
of you take your medicine so you don't
feel worse afterwards or you know prime
example of this would be exercise when
you get to the point of the exercise
where it's really hurting and you don't
really want to do it and you're tempted
to give up courage or fortitude is what
would allow you to get through that and
push through despite feeling some pain
from which from an epicurean perspective
might say well why would you ever want
to you know make yourself feel pain
precisely so that you feel better
afterwards
so that you don't get sick which is a
pain or a trouble right so you don't end
up with a body that's flabby and unable
to do the things that you want it to do
and that later on degenerates so that
you can put off your inevitable death we
could go on and on and on with examples
for this so courage is valuable
primarily in terms of helping us to deal
with things that are troublesome or
painful and torquatus here highlights
something that's really central to
epicurean philosophy courage is going to
make us able to deal with fears courage
bears upon fear and what are the things
that people are typically going to be
afraid of well one big thing is death
and as he says here the fear of death
plays havoc with with the calm the
peacefulness in the Latin and even the
tenor of life the status vitae alright
and the word there is per to bot or
meaning it disturbs it deranged as it
sets things out it continually bothers
us and so if we don't have courage and
we're constantly worried about death
whether it's you know something
immediate like you know or thinking
about oh I get in my car I could
actually get in an accident and get
killed even though the odds of that are
fairly low and I do have a lot of
control over how I Drive my own car
we're not gonna have a happy life so we
need courage in order to deal with these
fears of death death is inevitable it's
going to happen sooner or later
but we don't have to be thinking about
it in ways that are motivated by fear
long before it actually happens because
that's going to make life less enjoyable
also all sorts of pains of mind and body
so you know we can have worries about
physical pain oh man what if my liver
goes you know what if I get old
I'm already middle-aged myself so I can
tell you there's all sorts of muscle and
joint aches that you know start to
appear and you know some of them you can
figure out why and some of them you
can't and they can become a daily
occurrence many people live with chronic
pain of quite high intensity and the
Epicureans actually had quite a few
meditations on physical pain some of
them are encapsulated here one can
remind oneself for example by
recollecting that pains of great
severity are ended by death if you're in
really horrible pain there will look be
an end to it
slight pains have frequent intervals of
respite great great example that is the
mild arthritis right some days you feel
it some days you don't if you're feeling
it a lot well you know that's that's
unfortunate but you will have some ways
to deal with it and those of medium
intensity lie within our own control
says no set Domino's we are masters of
them to some degree we can bear them if
they are endurable or if they're not we
may serenely quit life's theater when
the play has ceased to please us some of
the ancients counseled suicide as a way
of dealing with things that we decide
are unbearable but for the most part
we're going to we're going to be able to
find them bearable it's possible and
courage as a virtue helps us do that
coming back to the death example another
thing that the Epicureans often said
the dead are only as they were before
they were born we don't have to worry
according to the Epicureans about some
terrible afterlife where we're gonna be
punished by some deities and we don't
even have to be all that concerned about
what's gonna happen say to our bodies
you know are they going to be eaten by
crows doesn't matter your your there's
no you anymore
so courage is partly cognitive it's
partly keeping things in mind but it's
also a virtue that's a habit it's
something that is affected helps us deal
with fear and has to do with actions
that we do over and over again another
thing that comes up in here is that
there are some associated States or
dispositions the lobe translation is a
little misleading in reading in that
that there are these other virtues which
is not actually in the text here but
these are definitely good states that
are associated for the Epicureans and
for some other virtue ethicists with
courage so we want to highlight these
endurance is a translation here of pot
ciencia pot ciancia comes from the word
meaning to suffer and being able to
endure or being able to take on that
suffering without allowing it to really
get you down and to put you out as we
could say industry is a decent way of
translating a city we toss diligence
would be another good way of translating
it taking something and sticking to it
you're going to notice that the
cognitive industry is used to translate
another's is the the Latin that's
translated by another term it's when we
say that somebody assiduously works at
something we mean that they continually
do it and that's part of courage as well
courage is what you exercise when things
start to get tough so you may in fact
need courage in this sense not to just
you know stand up to foes on the
battlefield or a mugger but to apply
gentle pressure continuous
in terms of something that your boss is
doing or something that your neighbor is
doing where you want it to change
watchfulness the ghillie I the plural
there right watchfulness you might say
instances of being watchful of keeping
vigil this is also quite important and
then finally what's translated here is
perseverance induced area right sticking
to something continually working at
things the epicurean life a lot of
people picture it as if it's just like
laying around having grapes fed to you
lying on a couch or something like that
but at least the way that the the roman
Epicureans are understanding it it does
involve courage and not just courage
again in the sense of like dealing with
immediate fears but dealing with things
that are difficult over and over again
until we develop a disposition where
they become no longer quite so difficult
for us again I want to remind you that
that the point of all of this exposition
and argument is to make the case that
courage is not actually a good thing in
its own right although we certainly may
praise it but it's something instead
that we need instrumentally it's
something we need as a tool so that we
don't have a bad life ironically we have
to take on some pain and suffering and
do so willingly in order to not incur
more down the line so courage is also
tied in with prudence or wisdom for the
Epicureans and that's the Epicurean
position